first of all as a director you're always
sort of a little nervous going into
whatever pairing you put together you
know whatever actor as you start to mix
and match and so this one was a little
unusual because it's father and son and
they're playing father and son the
nervousness that I was dealing with was
really born out of a respect for him and
not wanting to let him down
oddly enough when we started to work
that dissipated very quickly and our
processes are not very different which
was kind of cool to see and I think we
worked really really well together he's
a wonderful actor terrific and he's just
a very positive creative force in the
production of this it was great
whatever you needed to write to get to
the center of what the core of what you
thought the problem of the scene was of
the character everybody was available to
it lovely there's a very historic
element to this film and particularly
from that point of view to see and
Kieffer's I think he was a really
remarkable actor and of course Jack
Bauer of course his own history has been
pretty amazing and Donald as well
Donald's a legend really I've had the
good fortune of working with both Kiefer
and Donald and I was aware that they had
never worked together before and so as I
read the story between a father and son
i felt quite captivated by the personal
and professional opportunity that it
brought
there is nobody else and if there was
ever a time the man needed God it was
then and trust me he wasn't there if
you're expecting God to save you he
ain't gonna do with not you you went
looking for it God is not responsible
for the life you choose the thing that I
ended up walking away with which was the
most kind of profound kind of gift that
I got from this experience was I
realized and we spent nine weeks
together at least 14 hours a day focused
on building something together and that
ended up being the kind of the most
special gift that I got out of this
experience
q4 and I did 24 for pretty much seven
years and one of those things that you
do when you're sort of waiting for a
lighting setup or waiting for anything
on a television set or even a movie set
did you talk about the future and one of
the things that keeper and I always
talked about it was almost like a little
fantasy was the potential of doing a
Western
as a director in the television film
business there's nothing more exciting
that you hold in front of you as a
Western so I was into it he was into it
and we talked back and forth and then
suddenly it started to become real and
then it became not only just the Western
but a Western with his father Kieran
Donald really together for the first
time in a movie and that couldn't be
more attractive to me so it was a double
whammy a Canadian company got involved
mind's eye and so they started to put it
together and before you know it I'm
sitting on a western speed doing West
but I'm a huge fan of the western genre
and I got to work with Jon Cassar I
thought the story was fantastic I
thought it was casted beautifully you
know but ultimately this is the thing
that excited me the most of the thing
that I was I guess maybe even the most
nervous about was that I got to work
with my father for the first time
that's something I've wanted to do for
30-some odd years and couldn't think of
a better story that I would want to tell
with him so for all of those reasons but
primarily I got he said listen I have
this one it's a cowboy picture and I'd
love to make a cowboy picture some so we
did that
forsaken is a classic Western when I
first read the script I just kept
thinkin of some of the old John Ford
Western so some of the great Clint
Eastwood westerns Brad Merman wrote
really an amazing script really touching
emotional yet you know pretty
action-packed it sort of hearkened back
to the older westerns not sort of the
modern sort of revitalized westerns that
have been out recently you really sort
of had old-fashioned values that you
sort of imprint on today father and son
and the trouble between father and son
long-lost love it had all those
wonderful things this is dealing with a
lot of themes of love and loss and kind
of renewal
that's quite a moving story you know it
cost you emotionally to read that script
and that's a good thing
seconded it's it's not the kind of genre
that gets shot a lot anymore and and
it's cyclical you know a few of them
will come out yeah I'm wonderful
Unforgiven and so you get a couple to
come out because I'm forgiving was
successful and and so on and so forth
but I think everyone tries to imprint
this sort of really modern kind of look
to them and feel to them and I think
that it plays against what a Western
really is
you